who does tanjiro end up with and zanitsu
and even inosuke who does the wind
hashira love and who does Kiyu love all
of those questions along with every
other secret romance in Demon's hair
will be explained over the course of
this video so make sure to stay tuned
for this one because it's going to be
without a doubt my longest video ever if
you enjoy seeing detailed demonstrate
videos like this one and want to keep
them coming show the hasha with it and
slay that like button until you see
flashy fireworks tangent style join the
Slayer fan by subscribing and hitting
that notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
demon Sarah videos and updates and you
don't want that with the new season
right around the corner set your heart
Ablaze and without further Ado let's
jump into It spoilers and all tanjiro X
kanau Kano debuts as early as chapter 6
believe it or not during the final
selection exam we just see her gentle
smile and don't spend much time with her
but like Anya she was singled out
foreshadowing her future importance in
the story she was one of the almost 20
participants in one of the five to
actually serve survive so it wasn't
really love at first sight here since
Kana was just in the background as
Tundra was carrying out his goal of
trying to help save his sister let's
fast forward now to the nataguma
mountain Arc at this point she came with
guiyu and shinobu as her tuguko AKA as
her apprentice and eventual successor
again this wasn't a very romantic
meeting shinobu is trying to kill nazuko
because she's a demon while Tundra and
gear are trying to protect nezuko from
the insect hashira as guiyu is keeping
shinobu busy her assistant Connell
attacks Tundra as he's running away with
nezuko she almost kills nezuko tanjos
precious sister but Tundra manages to
stop her Kano is a beast though and then
manages to knock Tundra out with a kick
to the head as she chases down nazukul
part of her thinks it's weird that
nezuko is just running and not attacking
but another part of her says and I quote
just kill demons like I was taught end
quote at this point she is clearly not
allowing herself to think for herself
rather just following orders luckily the
crows let kanau know that nezuko is to
be captured rather than killed and then
she proceeds with those new instructions
so yeah not a conventional start to a
romance imagine a girl knocked you out
with a kick and tried to kill your
sister still arguably Kana was just
doing what the majority of demon Sayers
would do following orders and trying to
eliminate demons at the butterfly
Mansion things really begin to change
while the kakushi are carrying tanjira
there they see Kano and Tundra stares at
her as if it's the first time he truly
saw her as she smiles surrounded by
butterflies it's explained to Tanja that
she's a tsuguko a Demon Slayer who's
being trained by a hashira only the most
talented and highly skilled Fighters get
selected so she's very impressive Tundra
thinks that he saw her at final
selection but he didn't notice that she
stepped on him last night hilariously
enough while the kakushi asked if they
can enter Kano Just Smiles vacantly not
saying anything aoi then intercepts them
and leads them away but interestingly
enough Tundra stares back looking at
Canal clearly showing his interest in
this weird quiet girl who could also
kick his his butt the Butterfly Girls
including Kana and Ali help with their
training Tundra being more straight
laced doesn't make a big deal of this
fact while zaitsu freaks out when he
finds out saying the girls have nice
chests great butts and strong thighs
tendro does his best not to give in to
such thoughts since as he says he thinks
it's bad to train with such impure
motivations Kano was on another level
and continually beat the three demon
slaying Amigos in the game of tag and in
the cut throwing game they marveled at
her abilities and how even though she
joined at the same time she was so much
ahead of them Tundra was the opposite
and actually lied behind Zane TSU and
inosuke to the point where he felt
embarrassed still after losing to Canal
the unbeatable for five days straight
sending to any nosuke stop showing up
but tanjiro kept coming and working hard
and lost for another 10 days straight
Tundra wondered about why he couldn't
beat her and pointed out that she
smelled closer to a hashira and that her
eyes were different finally Tanja
realizes that the difference is that he
doesn't use total constant breathing 24
hours a day while the hashira and Kano
do we find out that Kano can use
breathing to burst huge hard gourds and
Tanger is shocked that a skinny girl
like her can do it through hard work and
total concentration breathing Tundra
manages to eventually catch Kano in tag
and to beat her in the cup game except
he doesn't want to throw the smelly
medical T in her face so he just sets
the cup on her head which still counts
as a win you gotta love these moments
they have and even though Tundra did
beat her here Kano actually had more
upper sleeve as we'll find out later but
the fact that these two are both such
strong Fighters also makes them a nice
match in my books a true power couple
now let's fast forward to when Tundra
thanks Kana for everything and is
heading out again again Kano smiles and
remains quiet there's an extended moment
of silence before Connell finally takes
out a coin and flips it after seeing the
result it's hilarious how
unintentionally cold and formal kano's
response is she states that I quote I
merely followed my teacher's
instructions so you don't need to thank
me goodbye and quote no nice to spend
time with you no I like you not even a
you're welcome nevertheless Tundra is
just shocked she spoke clearly Tundra is
drawn to kanau even in these earlier
parts of the story since not a lot of
people would stay so long considering
kano's Behavior Kano keeps repeating
goodbye while Tundra keeps talking
asking her about what she threw and why
she threw it then kind of opens up and
says and I quote I tossed this to the
side things for which I haven't been
told what to do just now I decided
whether I would speak to you or not
hence meant I wouldn't and Tails meant I
would it came up Tails so I spoke and
quote crazy to think if the end result
would have changed if she got heads and
didn't speak to Tundra but with how
persistent Tundra is it may not have
even mattered as Kano says goodbye again
for the thousandth time Tundra keeps the
conversation going asking Kano why she
can't decide for herself what to do no
response he continues and I quote what
did you want to do for yourself and
quote Kano not saying goodbye which is
progress in and of itself says it
doesn't matter nothing matters at all so
I can't decide by myself Tundra blows
her mind and heart wide open when he
says and I quote I think everything in
this world matters end quote he goes on
to tell her that he bets the voice and
her heart is soft but that it's also
important to follow instructions he
borrows her coin and surprise surprise
she says yes without flipping the coin
so Tundra has already started to get
Canal out of her robotic like existence
he then throws the coin and says that
this will decide if she listens closely
to the voice in her heart from now on if
it's heads she'll have to live by her
heart they usually calm and vacant kanal
is now Wide Awake And even sweating as
she awaits the result they both see his
heads and Tundras overjoyed and tells
Khanna that she can do it the heart is
what drives us her heart can get
infinitely stronger end quote it's like
Kano had been frozen in time in a sense
and she just melted during this exchange
and started to really live again by the
way tanju grabs the hands of the now
nervous Kana another clue that they'd
end up together as Tanja rushes off
saying goodbye Kano is now full of
energy and screaming after him how did
he know it would come up heads was
Tundra really leaving this all to fate
or chance kinda wants to know if it was
a valid throw she thinks to herself that
she was washing his hand and she doesn't
think that he cheated and this is one of
my favorite parts and demonstrator right
here Tundra smiles and says it was just
chance but here's the kicker and I quote
besides if it was Tails I was gonna flip
it over and over until I got heads and
quote Tantra was not going to lead this
to chance he was going to keep going
until he made sure that Kano started
listening to her heart he tells her to
take care as she remains there holding
the coin that Tundra had just held to
her heart when another girl catches her
off guard kind of straight up Falls over
clearly flustered about her Reawakening
feelings and after the scene between
Tanja and kanau no one should be
surprised that they end up together
tendro's consistent effort and interest
in kanau and the fact that kano's heart
was pretty much reawakened by him his
heavy foreshadowing for what's to come
so I don't want anyone saying that this
matchup came from Left Field since this
significant and life-changing scene was
in the very first season however there
are arguably match-ups that come from
left field and we'll get into those
later by the way because the nature of
this video I won't be focusing too much
on kano's backstory although I do go
into it in more detail in my how strong
is kind of video long story short though
she had a difficult upbringing she grew
up in poverty and in an abusive home she
witnessed siblings pass away and if she
cried she would get punished not
surprisingly she eventually broke
psychologically and was sold into
slavery before Kanai and shinobu saved
her although they physically rescued her
she was like an empty shell and kinda
had to give her a coin to flip before
she could make any decision thus tanjura
straight up mends her broken psyche here
and although she will still grow from
here the wheels are clearly turning
again making Tundra already one of the
most important figures in her life up to
this point now we fast forward to Tantra
waking up from his coma after the fight
against upper moons gutaro and daki
who's the first person he sees none
other than a concerned Canal who
straight up drops and breaks a vase when
she sees she's no longer the empty shell
she once was she reveals that he's been
unconscious for two months clearly she's
been looking after him and then she
gives us one of the most heartwarming
Smiles with what appeared to be tears
coming from her eyes and she tells
Tundra she is glad that he's awake full
ship ahead it's a moment that's easy to
gloss over if you're waiting to get to
the fight but it shows just how much
kanal has come to care about tanjiro the
fact that she's the first to see him
suggest that she in all likelihood spent
the most time by his bed now let's skip
over to connell's fight against upper
moon to Doma the whole fight is amazing
but I'll try to focus on the details
that stand out from a tundra and Kano
perspective the first thing I'll mention
and go back to is how Canal like tanjiro
the chosen one is an amazing fighter in
her own right making them quite the
power couple dolma says that Kano might
just be a little more skillful than
shinobu who he's just eaten and that's
before Kano even shows him her full
power this is an important fight for
Kano because she is avenging both Kane
and shinobu both of whom rescued her
from slavery and died at the hands of
Doma by this point Kano is definitely
not a vacant shell she is burning with
passion and specifically with hatred for
DOMA inosuke helps kanau in this fight
as the shinobu who poisoned Doma when he
ate her but Kano is still amazing in it
in her own right she uses one of my
favorite breath style techniques ever
called flower breeding final form
Vermilion eye which is pretty much like
a shotting gun with its own unique spin
it makes surrounding movements look dull
and slow and it causes pressure on the
eyes that stains them red kanau uses
this ability and with the help of
inosuke and chernobyl's poison succeeds
in defeating dolma finally carrying out
her revenge as a result of using this op
technique though she loses Vision in her
right eye after the battle we find out
that Kano couldn't cry for Kane after
she died but everyone was kind and
didn't think less of her because she
couldn't show emotion and finally she
cries harder than ever the floodgates
open symbolizing that with her defeat of
dolma she's fully regained her ability
to show her emotions similarly Tundra
completes his revenge Arc by finally
beating muzon with the help of everyone
and like kamau he loses Vision in his
right eye in the process and although
it's sad that they both lose their
Vision in one eye it's yet another thing
that for us hardcore Romantics makes
them seem destined for each other but
let's not gloss over this final battle
because there are quite a few important
moments concerning Kano and tanjiro
there is a point where muzon has taken
out almost everyone including the
strongest hashira and Kano looks like
the only fighter left he approaches her
and is about to finish her off and
Tundra swoops in with the save using the
legendary Dance of the fire god style
and takes kind of way to safety at this
point half of Tundra's face is mutated
but he doesn't seem to care he just
apologizes to Kano for being late and
tells the kakushi to take care of her
it's a complete 180 from the time kanau
easily not lock them out with a kick and
you love to see it however it's not just
Tundra doing the saving kano's turn
comes up when Tundra becomes an
overpowered demon Kano still had some
anti-demon medicine and when she sees
the state tanjarazin she realizes that
this is the reason she still has one eye
left kanau bless her heart uses
Vermillion eye with her one remaining
eye in order to save tanjiro she gets
hurt in addition to hurting her last
remaining eye with her special technique
but it doesn't bother her as she says
all she wishes for is for tanjiro to
come back to them and you can noticeably
see that her words reach him just as
Tundra said kanau Kano was willing to
risk not only her vision but her life to
save Tundra as well and this is the big
push which helps him return to the world
of humans as tanju recovers Kano is
laying down too being treated for her
injuries they make eye contact and both
smile and cry having saved each other
during chapter 204 the second last
chapter tanjan Canal share a great
moment after they've recovered to an
extent from their injuries they talk
about how the the first user of flower
breathing planted the sakura tree in
front of them and named it Victory Kano
wanted to tell the tree that they
succeeded and Tundra can't help but
think how kind this was of her they
continued to talk about how they're
doing and both the light in kaburamaru
the snake that Kano inherited from iguro
the serpent hashira although Kano
definitely lost some Vision in her
remaining eye by using Vermillion eye to
save tanjiro she does explain that she
still has some Vision left although they
part ways and Tundra is having dinner
with zenitu nazuko and inosuki at the
end of the chapter the next chapter
pretty much reveals who got together
with whom chapter 205 is a huge time
skip where we first meet the descendants
of Kano and tanjiro namely kanatakamado
who looks very similar to Kano and
sumihiko kamado who looks very similar
to tanjiro I have no doubt the name
Kanata itself is a reference to kano's
name and at this point some fans
suggested that the ships still weren't
official because descendants of these
characters might have gone together
rather than the main characters
themselves immediately I was like no way
to this possibility and the mangaka
clearly had my back and was kind enough
to create an extended ending where it
was confirmed that tanju and kanal did
get together and were Kanata and
sumihiko's great great grandparents in
this extended ending we also saw
flashbacks of tanjan Kano getting close
being nice to crows and being wrapped
around together by their pet snake
kaburamaru who was probably a good
wingman for tanjiro and in the final
panel Tundra is holding nezuko's hand
with his left hand and kano's hand with
his right which is perfect I love to see
them together in the final panel of the
series so there we have it the
relationship between Tundra and Kano
fully explained although it didn't seem
super promising at the start when Kano
knocked him out and tried to kill a
sister they got over that hurdle With a
Little Help from tantro's Amnesia since
he didn't even remember she did that
after tanjiro flipped that coin at the
butterfly estate there was arguably no
going back and their ship kept getting
more and more perfect from there they
were both willing to risk their lives
for one another and were both saved by
one another on multiple occasions and in
multiple ways days I truly love this
couple and after her terrible upbringing
I'm so glad Connell got with someone she
deserves someone as kind as tanjiro it
truly warms my heart every time I think
about this perfect ship in 72x nazuko
Zane to debuted in chapter 6 during the
final selection Arc along with Kano he
didn't really do anything he was just
singled out for a second a little
foreshadowing that he along with Kano
and ganya would be important to the
story moving forward he's one of the few
people to pass the exam and when we see
him next during chapter 8 he's the only
one of the four presents stricken by
fear after passing the exam thinking to
himself over and over again that he's
going to die even though he survived
here he'll die in the end he also gets a
sparrow while the others get a crow
which is pretty hilarious but yeah let's
keep in mind that one of the main things
we know about zain2 right from the
get-go is that he carries a lot of fear
this detail will make his later actions
for nazuko all the more significant it
is not until chapter 19 that we see
zenitu again and then we figure out
another important aspect character aside
from his fear the dude likes girls a lot
and is pretty Shameless when it comes to
pursuing them when Tundra sees him with
nezuko in his wooden backpack zaitu is
on his knees crying begging for a random
girl to marry him because he doesn't
know when he'll die he says please
countless times after Tundra saves the
girl from the awkward situation zaitsu
put her in she thanks him zaitu says the
girl likes him and is going to marry him
only to get slapped and repeatedly hit
by said girl until Tundra has to save
zenitu this time from the girl telling
her to calm down we then find out that
this girl is engaged and all she did was
ask Zain to if he was all right because
he looked sick at the side of the road
and somehow that led to zaitu thinking
she liked him and would marry him Saints
who doesn't blame himself after she
leaves but rather asks tanju why he
interfered and then we get the mimified
look of disgust from Tundra so yeah so
far zaitsu doesn't look so hot at this
point he's like a young frightened
Master roshi and Tundra looks at him as
if he were some truly pitiful creature
saying reveals that he's a swordsman
because a woman tricked him and put him
deep into debt and his trainer was an
old man who took on that debt so clearly
zenitsu does not have a good track
record with girls up to this point and
in part that's because he often chooses
the wrong girl to pursue whether she's
the kind that manipulates him for money
or the kind that's already taken zain2
joins Tanja on his journey and they go
to see about a demon in a house but they
just too scared and sweaty to want to go
in at first but tanjos look up disdain
and pity finally makes him agree to go
despite his fear Tanja leaves nezuko
still in her box with the scared
children but they leave her when they
hear scratching it is at this point that
Tundra says that box holds the thing I
value most more important than my life
itself when Tangerine zaitsu gets
separated say to the media plan is to
make it back outside with a boy zait was
so scared that the boy is worried more
about zenitu rather than himself zaitu
sees a demon he passes out he enters
Avatar mode and defeats it and
eventually he makes it outside where he
protects the box that goes in from
inosuke who keeps hitting him now here
for the first time zenitu's shown a very
respectable side of himself despite all
of his fear he was ready to take
whatever punishment inosuke could dish
out in order to protect nazuko's box yes
he didn't really know nazuko yet but
it's significant that she's tied in a
way to this big moment of his you could
already say that she brought out the
best of him even this early on when
Tundra comes out of the house and sees
what's happening zaitsu tells tanjur he
protected this because Tundra said it
was more important than his own life
this moment would have been powerful no
matter what but it's way more powerful
because we saw how over the top scared
zaitsu always seemed to be up to this
point yet consciously he decided to help
his new friend despite all the fear and
the pain as we find out he knew from the
start that a demon was in the Box
because of his amazing sense of hearing
and yet in all his life he never heard a
sound that was so full of kindness as
the sound that tanjiro makes so he
decides to trust that there's a good
reason for tajo carrying around demon
and he will protect it no matter what
until he can ask Tundra directly about
it it's amazing characterization for
xanitsu and when Tundra sees a beat up
zaitu gripping the box to protect it he
has flashbacks of what happened to his
family possibly even foreshadowing
saints's eventual inclusion into
Tundra's family but also showing him
that this blonde dude is actually worthy
of friendship and maybe even worthy of
being the person that protects nazuko am
I getting a little ahead of myself yeah
but all of these moments take on new
significance when we know what's to come
either way eventually Tundra
acknowledges zanitsu as a really great
guy when he finds out that he protected
the Box despite knowing a demon was in
it Tundra even said that from the start
his sense of smell told him that
contrary to appearances zaitsu is
actually good and strong so this was
just saying to proving what Tundra
already sensed already things are
looking good for zaitsu because of
course Tundra wouldn't mind his sister
ending up with a good strong guy who
would protect nezuko even before meeting
her despite how scared he was and the
risk he had to under undertake in doing
so then we get the first official
face-to-face meeting of Zain to anezuko
at first zaitsu is horrified when she
begins coming out only to fall in love
with her at first sight when he actually
sees her in his view she straight up
Sparkles despite being a demon zaitsu's
first thought is to be jealous of
tanjiro because he has it so good being
with this cute girl every day and
traveling in pure Bliss keep in mind
zaitsu doesn't let Tundra explain that
it's his sister at first so zaitsu is
appalled that he went through so much
suffering just so Tundra could be all
lovey-dovey with a girl after finding
out she was Tundra's sister the entire
time zaitsu was on his best behavior
wanting to obtain Tundra's forgiveness
after all you want to be on good terms
with a brother if you want to marry the
sister one of the first things any two
did was present Mexico with flowers
something we'd all recognize as a
romantic gesture for a girl you like for
example it was a complete 180 from utter
despair to Blissful hope that he now had
a chance to end up with nezuko unlike
Kano and tanja's relationship from the
moment zaitu sees nezuko his feelings
are very obvious there is no doubt that
he likes her and wants to marry her the
only question is will she want to marry
him during the natagumo mountainark
mission at first Saints who doesn't
follow them up that scary Mountain but
as soon as he remembers that Tundra has
nesuko with him he rushes to catch up
calling Tundra an idiot for taking a
girl someplace dangerous again we start
to see how nezuko is the key for Zion to
overcoming his character flaws like
being paralyzed by excessive fear and
also eventually not being as crazy about
every girl because he has his own that
he can direct all of his love towards
and because nezuko is a good person
he'll no longer have to be worried about
being manipulated for money which got
him here in the first place on the
mountain when he's scared he also
motivates himself by thinking of his
head on nezuko's lap if he were dreaming
and he woke up with nezuko he would work
really hard he says he'd even plow three
Fields it's telling that she's the one
person he thinks about not any other
woman when he finds himself in a
nightmare spider felt situation like
this one we find out that zeins who
didn't have parents so no one ever
expected anything of him until his
Gramps AKA his Sensei he thinks of
nezuko when he thinks about a dream of
spending his whole life protecting
others or making them happy his Gramps
never giving up on him inspires him to
actually try to pursue such a dream and
gives him strength to defeat his enemy
spider demon in Epic fashion still he
manages to get so poisoned that he
thinks he's going to die and in this
situation he chooses to apologize to
nezuko rather than anyone else before
shinobu saves him then we jump to the
rehabilitation Arc where we find out
despite his love for nazuko thanks to
stealing to other girls as well even if
the emotions are more superficial
compared to what he feels for nezuko
when he finally gets to participate in
Rehabilitation training he gets crazy
excited about the idea of getting to
touch the girls getting massages from
them getting to touch their hands with
the cup game and getting to grab them
for the tag game he's so angry that
Tundra and inosuke made it seem terrible
when the training is actually Heaven
because they got to do all the above
mentioned stuff with attractive girls
that smell all great and for a while he
really did enjoy those excruciating
massages from Ali and laughed during
them while tanjani nosuke were more
likely to cry from the pain so it would
be a stretch to say that thing to stop
looking at other girls when he met
nezuko but notably he wasn't as pathetic
anymore getting on his knees and begging
other girls to marry him and although he
clearly was still attracted to other
girls nezuko was always the main girl he
kept coming back to in his thoughts the
Saints who even stopped coming to see
Canal when he kept losing to her in the
tag game and the cup game despite the
fact that as he previously mentioned it
was a joy to just look at such
attractive girls my point is although he
still did embarrassing things he clearly
wasn't as desperate as he was before but
women still did have a strong effect on
him as we saw when shinobu used her
charms to motivate him so that he could
Master total concentration breathing in
only nine days significantly though at
the end of the day he'd always seemed to
come back to nezuko as we saw in chapter
51 he talked to her while she was still
in her box about his day and what
happened nezuko would scratch the box to
communicate back with zaitsu could
apparently use his old pieces of hearing
to understand and hearts would appear
around him as he promised to take her to
wear the flower he brought her was
blooming this is just one small scene in
the story but such an important one
because it lets us know that off-screen
Saints and nezuko have been
communicating and spending a lot of time
together and all those 92 gets
physically attracted to other girls the
hearts that appear around him which
connote his love are reserved for nezuko
at the end of chapter 51 during the
bonus page where the mangaka usually
gives us some fun extra sketches we see
that zaitu is showing let's go goldfish
and she seems to be in love with the
sight of them he brought them to nezuko
without asking shinobu and later got
chewed out by OWI for doing it which
goes to show the length he'll go to to
make nazuko happy these little moments
are important because they show this
isn't a one-sided relationship nezuko
has mentioned communicates back with
Zane so and appears to enjoy spending
time with him and bonus points go to
zenitsu for being so nice and caring
when it comes to the way he treats
nezuko at the end of chapter 54 on the
bonus page we see 72 with hearts in his
eyes carrying nezuko while literally
jumping for joy notably nezuko is
evidently laughing joyfully as well
after seeing this bonus page it's not
surprising that zenitsu dreams about he
and nezuko running through a field
during the Mugen train Arc so that's
clearly his greatest wish which is sweet
obviously he cares about tundra 2 and
others but you'll notice that nezuko
takes priority over everyone here
including all of the girls of his past
and the girls of the butterfly estate
who he found attractive as well he
dreams of making a ring of flowers for
nezuko arguably a metaphorical wedding
ring in this instance and nezuku agrees
Saints who doesn't just dream of her
saying yes to him though he also
imagines doing acts of service for her
like carrying her on his back over a
river because she can't swim in contrast
Tundra dreamed of his family inosuke
dreamed of the whole gang only he was
the clear leader and then Goku dreamed
of his brother so it was the only one to
dream of a romantic other which goes to
show how much he cares about that's go
and how much she means to him Wednesday
NATO finds the infiltrator in his
subconscious he tells him that only
nezuko is allowed in there again
reiterating how important she is to him
when the school gets into trouble and
caught by the demon train in real life
Saints who comes to the rescue and frees
her using his Thunder breathing
proclaiming that he will protect nezuko
and nezuku is visibly touched before
zyansu starts snoring revealing that
he's still asleep at the end of chapter
65 for the bonus page we straight up see
nezuko serving as a lab pillow for the
sleeping zenitsu and holding his head so
yeah at this point you got to be pretty
crazy to think that these two will not
end up together compared to Tanja and
kanau we've gotten so many scenes and
clues that these two are going to end up
together and even though it seems pretty
one-sided at first glance a closer
examination reveals that nezuku does
seem to care about zenitsu and he
clearly makes her happy and that'll
become only more clear later on after
the battle with akaza we're told that
Zane to stop whining even when he went
on missions alone he did ask for a lock
of nezuko's hair though so that he'll
fight harder although that probably
seems weird to most of us now it wasn't
that unheard of in the past that a dude
would keep a lock of his Love's hair
with him so again it's symbolic of
zaitsu and nazuko's relationship and how
he wants to symbolically keep her with
him at all times even when they're away
from each other the thought of her gives
him motivation and when he ran with
tanjira and inosuke he motivated himself
by simply yelling out nezuko's name
repeatedly this my friends is a man
deeply in love if I've ever seen one
from this moment on seizure still wants
to protect other girls or come running
if he hears them crying or show his Envy
when he hears that the sound hashira has
three wives but nezuku is the consistent
girl he thinks about and the one he
wants to make his wife he's no longer as
indiscriminate in his advances towards
women as a roshi or aminita now let's
fast forward all the way to when nezuko
becomes immune to the Sun and starts
speaking again of course the question is
for the purpose of this video what does
she say to zainitsu and how design to
respond to the fact that she can speak
now and go out in the sun well as you
may have imagined zantoo is over the
moon he can't help but scream and other
girls are begging him to be quiet but
notably Nesco blushes and smiles saying
welcome back to zenitu the contrast
between her reaction compared to that of
the other girls is another great sign
for zenitsu he says that nezuko is so
cute he could die now and almost
immediately asks if they can finally get
married now his Expressions say it all
just how insanely obsessed he is with
nezuko he begs nezuko multiple times to
marry him and Promises to feed her Sushi
and eel every day and then nezuko says
welcome back inosuke which makes zanitsu
immediately want to kill inosuke the
thing is nezuku is not fully back to
normal and Her speech is still limited
so when inosuke spent the last two days
trying to get nezuko to say his name
it's not surprising that she said it
here but it's hilarious how it comes off
so that Zanes was so clearly obsessed
with dezuko on the one hand and she
appears to not even recall who he is of
course Saints who is not discouraged and
continues to be persistent the only time
zenitsu took a break from being his
Nesco obsessed self was when he realized
that his Sensei died took his own life
because native Senpai kaigaku who also
trained under his Sensei became a demon
at that point Saints who starts
preparing to defeat him and even Tundra
notices he's not his usual self and So
zanitu eventually does confront kaigaku
who is now upper Moon 6. Saints who in a
sense has to earn his Happy Ending by
confronting his fear and his past and
against kaigaku he actually speaks
arrogantly in contrast to his old
frightened self he calls kaigaku too
slow and eventually finishes kagaku with
his own original seventh form of Thunder
breathing zaitu's new attack is so fast
that the demon enhanced kaigaku can't
even see it finally after he faces past
and Avenged his Sensei or Gramps as he
called him seitsu has arguably earned
his happy ending not only has he been
persistent with nazuko he's also proven
through his actions that he is worthy of
her of course zaitsu will still help in
the fight against muzon but there's no
doubt that his finest moment combat wise
and character development wise was his
Triumph against kaigaku and upper moon
and the man responsible for sensei's
death the dude beat an upper Moon by
himself while he was conscious such a
great moment and I can't wait to see it
animated now fast forward to the final
moves on fight during chapter 1 96
nezuku starts reverting back into a
human and all her memories start to
flood in as well and along with them she
sees a memory of zenitsu offering her
flowers showing that she has not
forgotten His Kind gestures around the
same time zaitsu shows up to help fight
muzon being the best brother-in-law ever
since who promises to touch her that
he's not going to die rather than just
going home with a human nezuko without
hesitation he risks his life fighting
the strongest demon in an attempt to
save tanjiro and get slammed into a
building in the process my boy gets back
up to Muson surprise and even with a
broken leg is able to use his seventh
form flaming Thunder God against muzon
he keeps fighting helping Tundra finally
pin moves onto the wall so that he won't
be able to escape the sun after the
whole giant baby moves on thing Tundra
starts to become the Demon King he
attacks everyone indiscriminately and of
course zenitude with tears in his eyes
tries to get through to him asking
Tundra what about nezuko will he really
become a demon and hurt her like that
right after she just returned to being a
human again at this point it's made
pretty clear that even before the
marriage of Nesco and zenitsu Tundra
zenitsu and inosuke considered each
other brothers so this fight against
demon Tundra is understandably extremely
hard for them inosuke can't bring
himself to kill Tundra and eventually
nazukul steps in in order to try and
stop him she hugs him and Tundra bites
her not surprisingly zenitsu jumps in
and hugs Tundra too telling him to stop
and that he's killing nazuko as nezuko
continues to get hurt the Saints who
cries calling out her name unfortunately
after all the fighting he's pretty much
out of commission and he can't stop
tanjiro luckily as we discussed Kano
comes to the rescue with the medicine
and that along with everyone's feelings
reached tanjiro and he becomes a human
yet again and just as he promised 92
gets to take Tundra and let's go back
home although if we're being literal
nezugo actually takes zenitsu but we'll
get to that soon before that though we
do get a great part where Tundra is back
to normal any nosuke comments that the
injuries Tundra gave him are not a big
deal but saintsou says that for the rest
of Tundra's life he'll make him regret
what he did to his wife nazuko now fully
human and more shy than her demon self
is nervous at hearing the word white and
is shown sweating but significantly
enough she doesn't say she won't be
xanax's wife during chapter 204 we get a
moment with sanami the wind hasha and
nazuko remember sanami heard nazuko and
wanted to kill her while she was a demon
and so this is an important scene where
he finally apologized and pretty much
admitted he was wrong about her he saw
his little brother and her and so went
to Pat her on the head sonomi is an
older guy and not nezuko's brother so
she gets embarrassed sweating and
blushing as he says take care we see
zenitsu spying on them and he gets angry
and jealous wondering what it is he just
saw however he has nothing to worry
about since he ends up being the one who
goes to live with nezuko and tanjiro
along with enosuke we get scenes of
nezuko petting and comforting zanitsu
when he complains about it being dark
and how hungry he is and although he's
tired he definitely doesn't mind being
comforted by nezuko when tangerinesuko
make it home they are greeted and hugged
by a neighbor and hilariously enough
zantoo joins in on the hug while inosuke
watches confused like what is this hug
thing when they pray for the deceased
significantly enough Tundras on one side
of nezuko and zaint was on the other on
the last page zayto nesgar are sitting
and eating beside each other they're
smiling at each other and passing food
as Hearts continue to float around
zainsu's head and that is it the ending
of the story before we jump to the giant
time skip that reveals the descendants
of our main characters in this Final
Chapter we find out that yes in fact
zeitsu and nezuko did get together and
their descendants are called yoshiteru
agatsuma a 17 year old who looks like
zenitsu with black hair and his older
sister the 18 year old Toko agatsuma who
looks exactly like nezuko in fact the
chapter starts with yoshiteru AK
zaitsu's great grandson reading a book
zainitsu wrote about their demon sang
Adventures the hilarious thing is also
that he called the book The Legend of
zenitsu that definitely cracked me up
and at the end of the chapter we see a
framed image of our main characters in
The Commodore house and nezuku enzymes
were shown together both leaning into
each other and that is the end of the
series or at least that was the end
before we got the bonus extended ending
that was released within the final
volume of the manga from Jose to a Nesco
perspective it does give us some
significant extra information we get
scenes of tundra and asuko beginning to
cry when they sense the presence of
their family when they come home and
zaisu joins in on the cry and group hug
and this time a nervous ignosuke even
tries his hand at the group hug another
hilarious moment we get some more panels
of Zayn too looking all lovey-dovey at
nezuko and thinking that she's too
obliged to a nosuke when he insists on
having his height measured immediately
we are also told that because the after
effects of Santa's injuries he kept
crying about his painful legs while they
walked to put flowers on all the graves
and while inosuke ignored him nezuku
decided to carry him on her shoulders so
sweet we also get some more information
on The Descendants and see yoshiteru and
toko's two little sisters one of whom
looks like a female zenitsu with the
same eyebrows very cute we see some
other scenes including more scenes of
zaito and let's go laughing together and
even a scene that could be nezuko and
zaitsu getting married where zaitsu
finally puts that ring of flowers that
he dreamed of making on nezuko's head to
her great delight and his Sparrow even
helps him which is a nice disney-esque
touch a happy ending for these two is
exactly what we wanted and needed in
this final panel just as Tundra's
holding kano's hand zanetus holding
nezuko's as they look off into the sky
together and that is it everything there
is to know about zenitu and nezuko's
relationship which is in many ways the
most focused on ship in the entire
series although I explained how an
observant person could pick up on the
fact that Tanja and Kano would end up
together it's much more obvious with
zenitsu and nezuko as from the get-go
since it was extremely upfront about his
romantic feelings and repeatedly asks
nezuko to marry him I hope I've also
shown that there were signs that not
only did zenitsu show feelings for
nezuko but nezuko also showed signs that
she'd end up with zenitu as well she
always and enjoyed his company unlike
many other girls and when she became
fully human again she was ready to fully
return his feelings this relationship is
in part such a satisfying one because it
was always so obvious how much zeins who
loved nazuko and so I was really rooting
for him to get his happy ending with her
especially considering his past where he
was completely alone except for women
who used him for money and eventually
his Sensei he started out as an orphan
but ended up being a part of this
beautiful family with nezuku and tanjiro
and they clearly go on to start their
own family as well that will continue to
have many descendants for nezuko it's a
win too because she doesn't get the
obsessed over every woman scaredy cat
that zenitu was in the beginning of the
series rather zaitsu has grown from
begging random girls on the street to
marry him to focusing on one that likes
him and will treat him right he also was
always very kind and conservative even
when others couldn't see her as a human
and just viewed her as a demonic monster
furthermore he proved that he was able
to overcome his fear when it came to
protecting nezuko and Witness school
there to motivate him he ended up
becoming one of the strongest Swordsmen
alive inosuke X OWI out of the three
main relationships from the series this
one is probably the one that comes out
of left field the most which is part of
what makes it such an interesting one to
discuss and we'll go into reasons why it
feels a bit random as we also analyze
the story for Clues avinosuke and aoi's
interest in one another inoska actually
appears to be younger than aoi inosuke
is 15 years old while in the first demon
Sarah light novel flower of Happiness
aoi reveals that she's older than the 16
year old Kano thus she's either 16 and a
few months older than Kano or even older
than 16. well you know we have their
similarities and differences the
sometimes girl face sometimes boar faced
inosuke is short-tempered and aoi
reveals in the novel that she also has
an impatient personality they both
aren't afraid to speak their mind
however there are also differences while
inosuke is introduced to us as someone
who loves fighting with strong opponents
and gathered Pride from winning battles
Ali will scare the battle and viewed
herself as human human trash that was
lucky to survive final selection Ali
carried around feelings of inferiority
because she thought that there was no
value to a squad member who didn't kill
demons but only helped take care of
injured Squad members and carried out
physical rehabilitation we'll get to
this in the main story but in the novel
it's also mentioned that she trembled
uncontrollably when the sound hashira
ordered her to follow him on a mission
so in Stark contrasting nosuke she is
most definitely not a fighter so they
have a bit of an opposite attract thing
going on there thus their division of
labor is pretty traditional she can cook
and help heal in those case injuries
while he can protect her from physical
threats whether human animal or demon so
now that we have a basic understanding
of their personalities and how they mesh
with each other let's jump into the main
story and search for clues of Love Ali
makes her debut in chapter 48 when
tanjura arrives to the butterfly estate
Ali is one of the girls that helps out
there and let's just say she's not shy
if shinobu isn't there aoi is pretty
much in charge and her orders go since
kanau doesn't really respond or talk to
people at this point after tanjan the
demonstrate helper ask Connell questions
and things get awkward because she just
continues to smile without answering
them it's aoi who finally shows up and
breaks the tension she has a commanding
presence and this is what I meant about
her not being shy in the least she
screams who the hell are you to tanjiro
and the helper causing them both to
tremble in fear I don't want this to
come off as a negative even though it
tends to have negative connotations but
you could say that very much like
inosuke aoi is a loud mouth loudmouth
refers to someone who tends to talk a
lot in an offensive or tactless way and
that's exactly what we see happening
here that hell she used in her dialogue
wasn't dropped in there by accident it's
there to give us a sense of her
personality which is very unique among
the female characters we've come to know
so far you can imagine how loud inosuke
and her future home might be with both
of their aggressive and Loud
personalities clashing she goes on to
order tanjun the helpers to follow her
and start stomping off another parallel
with inosuke who loves pretending that
he's the boss and that tanjiro and Zayn
tour is underlings when zaitu is causing
trouble she tells him to pipe down right
him in the process she's the opposite of
a pushover and tells xanitsu that if he
doesn't behave she'll tie him down same
treatment starts crying telling Tundra
that he was stabbed and poisoned by a
spider but are we getting angry at him
is even worse it's hard not to
appreciate Howie's strong personality
and No Nonsense approach here she
definitely debuts with a bang and even
though she is suffering from a sense of
inferiority at this point as we'll find
out it adds depth to her character if
she can unabashedly run the show and
tell actual demon Sayers what to do
without being the least bit apologetic
about it inosuke is actually not his
usual self at this point his throat got
crushed and he's depressed just being
quiet in his bed as the great reunion
with Tundra is taking place even though
AWI and nosuke were in the same room
here there was no focus on their
relationship no interaction that we can
point to so compared to the zaitsu going
crazy over seeing nazuko scene and
tanjos looking back at Kano as the
helpers are taking him away this scene
is interesting and notable because it
doesn't include anything special it
clearly wasn't love at first sight with
these two as far as we can tell which
makes sense when one of the people is
wearing a boar mask after all and since
inosuke is the youngest too it makes
sense that he'd be the last one to
mature and start noticing girls during
these butterfly estate chapters we are
also told by the author that there's a
rumor that aui was the one who repaired
nazuko's box we're told she's got skills
as she wears an angry face but is
working on fixing nazuko's box it
captures her character well she seems
like an angry hateful person sometimes
but is actually really nice sort of like
a tsundere unlike zenitsu inosuke did
not enjoy the idea of girls loosening up
his muscles and getting the chance to
grab alien Kano in a tag game when
zaitsu is psyched about the prospect
inosuke simply says I quote stop talking
nonsense losing to those tiny girls is
embarrassing end quote showing that his
mind was obviously not on girls at this
point in his life unlike zenitus zaysu
even calls you know scale for his
naivete saying that he Betsy nosuke
never even spent any time with girls
before only for inosuki to misunderstand
and say that he stepped on Plenty of
girls even though we don't see aoi
showing signs she likes you know we do
see signs she doesn't like or appreciate
zionsu's advances she doesn't like it
when zaitsu holds her hand and beats him
up for grabbing her during the tag game
it's hilarious to watch because as zait
was trying to win her over not even
willing to throw the drink in her face
inosuke is not trying at all he has no
qualms about throwing the drink in her
face and even grabs her by the feet and
hangs her upside down during tag even
though all he had to do was touch her to
win knowing what we know now all these
earlier parts are hilarious aoi would go
on to develop feelings or maybe even is
developing feelings at this point for
the guy who isn't the least bit
concerned with being nice or polite to
her and I mean she isn't too concerned
with being polite herself so it's not a
surprising match when the gang is
leaving for the Mugen train Arc how he
is nice enough telling tanjiro that it
wasn't long but she's glad they got to
spend time together and she wishes
Tundra good luck this is the really
sweet moment when Tundra thanks her for
taking care of them and says that it is
thanks to her that he can fight again
aoi says compared to them she's not
import important so the thanks isn't
necessary she survived file selection
due to pure luck and since then she's
been afraid to fight so she's just a
coward Tundra really hits her
emotionally when he says that it doesn't
matter that she doesn't fight demons she
helped him so she's a part of him now
he'll think about her when he goes into
battle you can tell by the panel and she
is very touched by Tundra's words Tundra
goes on to talk to Kano after this and
Kano actually blushes in the manga after
he leaves while Audi doesn't it's not
romantic with Ali and tanjiro but it's
still a big deal because Tundra
transformed aoi's self-image here
instead of viewing herself as a coward
who is useless and should at the very
least heal people who are her superiors
tendra tells her at her part or role is
just as important and that if the people
she saves go on to defeat demons it's
her Victory too because she is a part of
them now unfortunately we don't get to
see nosuke's parting words to aoi here
if they did specifically feel the need
to exchange any after all in those cases
his own Beast who doesn't follow usual
conventions and while Tanja and zainitsu
are shown tearing up at their parting
with the little butterfly State girls
inosuke is just wearing his mask and we
see no tears still the fact that aoi
uncharacteristically said she enjoyed
spending time with the trio could be a
sign that she liked having inosuke
around as well after the Mugen train Arc
the gang is at the butterfly State again
one day Tundra is returning from a solo
Mission and this is when he overhears
how he screams while tangent the sound
hashira is trying to forcefully take her
on a mission she looks very scared and
nervous she sweats as she tells the
hasha who is carrying her to let her go
he even tries to take one of the younger
girls at first who aren't even core
members and accordingly aren't wearing
the demon Sarah uniform I briefly
mentioned this near the beginning of the
video but it really is touching that
when aoi screams out for kano's help
Kano actually moves to hell she sweats a
lot as she thinks about her Duty the
fact that tengen is a superior officer
and so on but then she recalls Tundra's
advice to obey her heart and that gives
her the strength to grab hold of Ali Ali
has brought to Tears by the fact that
Kano who for a long time just followed
the orders of superiors finally broke
that rule as far as the demon certain
code goes it appears like tangent is in
his right to do this he implies that he
only has to ask for shinobu's permission
to take a demonstrator graduate on a
mission if she is a tsuguko AKA The
Chosen successor of a hashira thus he
couldn't take Kana without asking
shinobu but he could take Ali official
Demon Slayer rules aside though everyone
realizes how wrong he is from an ethical
standpoint and Tundra steps in to help
he tries to head by tengen but for once
his super effective headbutt misses
because of tank and speed finally tendro
insists that if Tenga needs help he'll
go instead of Ali zanito and inosuke
show up at this point and inosuke says
before xanitsu and I quote I just got
back but I'm not tired I don't mind
going either end quote it's not quite a
proclamation of love but whenever
inosuke seems to be doing something nice
for someone else you gotta stop and
notice and in this case he does it on
his future wife's behalf their feelings
for each other aren't very clear yet but
the evidence that they like each other
and want to help each other is slowly
growing and it's probably not lost on
aoi that inosuke was willing to risk his
life on a dangerous mission to save her
from having to do so it's true that
Tanja and zanitu were willing to do so
too but they are already occupied with
budding love interests like Kano and
nezuko now let's fast forward to chapter
100 after a true come back from their
upper Moon 6 fight kanau is by Tundra
aside but aoi isn't aoi comes in after
Tundra wakes up crying because she
blames herself for all their serious
injuries after all as she points out
they were hurt because they went instead
of her Tundra finds out that tengen and
zaitu's injuries weren't as bad as his
but when he asks about inosuke one of
the butterfly State girls says he was in
danger for a while too she's not crying
at delivering this news but aoi is
crying a lot it's actually quite the
touching panel she says I quote
inosuke's condition was really bad the
poison got deep in him so he was slow to
use breathing to stop the bleeding and
end quote she doesn't even finish her
sentence before Tundra spots inosuke on
the roof this is a significant moment
and where we finally get always
specifically worrying and crying about
inosuke in a way other girls don't we
can assume that while kanal was by tanju
Sai the most AWI was by NOS case it's
clear that no other girl present
hadinosuke on her mind and in her
thoughts as much as aoi while inosuke
calls himself Immortal and one of the
little girls calls him dumb it's aoi who
steps in and holds inosuke back from
attacking her she yells at him saying
the poison doesn't work well on inosuke
but neither does medicine so he has to
be careful she criticizes him for
already forgetting that shinobu told him
this but her outward frustration clearly
points to her caring about inosuke after
all she wouldn't get so wound up if she
didn't care about what happened to him
inos gas layers as usual tells aoi to
shut up and to stop pulling on him and
even calls her a shrimp only for her to
say that they aren't that different in
height it's a funny relationship dynamic
between two short-tempered loud mouths
with hearts of gold that's completely
different from the other romantic
relationship Dynamics we see in the
series and even though they can both act
like 2 and haven't confessed their
feelings to each other after this there
is good reason to ship them besides just
the fact that the other characters
already shipped with each other aoi was
deeply affected by his injuries and
continues to get emotional about it even
though he's fine now and continues to
care about him warning him that he needs
to be careful despite him continuing to
be rude to her as usual and you can also
assume that they wouldn't care to bicker
with each other so much if they had no
feelings for each other it's been said
that the opposite of Love isn't hate but
indifference and these two are
definitely not indifferent with one
another we also find out during
shinobu's fight against Doma that aoi's
family was killed by demons just like
inosuke's mother was killed by a demon
namely dolma it's significant that
inosuke helped defeat Doma since it was
revenge for his mother but it was also
revenge for shinobu one of the most
important people in owie's life now
let's fast forward to after the world is
saved from the demon king of Pop inosuke
and Ali get another telling scene
inosuke is walking around the butterfly
estate thinking about how hungry he is
he starts stealing food while owie is
cooking and she calls him out for it
inosuke lies but wonders how she notices
so fast and that maybe she's strong
which is definitely a plus in inosuke's
books and then we get an adorable part
where aoi gives enosuke his own plate
and says that when he's hungry he can
eat from it this plate will just be for
him so he can eat from it whenever he
wants to the implication is that she'll
keep refilling it and making special
meals for inosuke inosuke this time is
the one who stares at Ali and blushes he
looks down at the food and you see
possibly the cutest smile in the series
plaster on his face finally we have hard
evidence that inosuke is into aoi too
and the way into his heart is through
his stomach then all that's left except
some bonus material we'll get into in a
bit is the confirmation that they end up
getting together and we get this in the
form of Al bahashibira the great
grandson avinosuke naui even before it
was confirmed that AWI was the
grandmother it was suggested since the
Allah in Alba seemed to come from the
Allah in aoi then there's the new more
detailed ending they included in the
final demonstrator volume that gives us
some scenes that fill in some of the
gaps between chapter 204 and chapter
205. there's even one panel that shows
what looks like inosuke presenting his
idea of a gift which seems to be some
stuff he just scavenged from nature to
aoi and aoi being genuinely touched to
receive it it appears to be a throwback
to inosuke's dream during the Mugen
train Arc as well where he presents
nezuko with some acorns and says look
I'll give you these sparkly acorns come
on and quote he clearly Associates it
with being a nice gesture and with it
being a way to get people to come with
him our boy has legit started to act
like xanitu who's always picking flowers
for nezuko we also get a bit of info on
their great grandson Alba here like that
he is 28th lost his job plays badminton
with tanjiro and kano's descendant and
has one little brother luckily the
mangaka makes up for the lack of focus
on this relationship in the main story
by focusing on it in the bonus materials
like in the demonstrator fan books in
the second fan book it's revealed that
whenever nezuko visited the Kana now an
hourly once a month inosuke would go
with her scientu hated him for it but
more importantly it gave him nosuke the
time he would have needed to grow closer
to aoi and vice versa furthermore in the
second fan book it's revealed that aoi
doesn't smile much but inosuke was able
to make her laugh Often by doing
unexpected things that's a sweet tidbit
of information and helps us in part
understand why they'd end up together
inosuke was special for being able to
make aoi the female gyu smile often and
to those confused by the female guiyu
comment Kiyu is famous in the demon sail
world for not smiling and that is it for
the slow-key couple although it was the
least focused on relationship of the big
three I hope I showed how it didn't come
from nowhere and there were subtle Clues
earlier on that these two May well end
up together aside from just their at
times strikingly similar personalities I
genuinely love these two as a couple and
she definitely brought out some of
inosuke's cutest moments which is saying
a lot since inosuke tends to be manly
most of the time rather than cute iguro
X mitsuri open igoro is the snake or
serpent hashiron he's 21 years old and
when the mangaka ranked each hashka's
physical strength via how well they do
in an arm wrestling contest iguro ranked
below everyone exception Nobu who we
know is not even physically strong
enough to cut off a demon's head this
means that yes iguro is physically
weaker than the 19 year old love hashira
mitsuri he also eats way less being able
to go three days without eating and he
tends to give off a much darker Vibe
compared to mitsuri's bright and warm
one it's definitely a situation where
Opposites Attract and in this case there
is clearly some subversion of
traditional gender Norms as well as I
mentioned igoro is physically weaker and
we were even told that he'd rank lower
than the 14 year old muichiro and the
nanhasha tanjuro in the arm wrestling
competition another interesting detail
is that mitsuri is taller than iguro
mitsuri is 167 centimeters or about 5
feet and 6 inches and iguro is 162
centimeters or about 5 feet and 4 inches
so we covered some fundamental and into
professional stuff about these two but
now let's jump into the manga and see
how the Love Story evolved over time
although they already knew each other by
this point igoro fully debuts during
chapter 45 of the manga it's the
hashiram meeting and in contrast to the
forgiving mitsuri iguro wants to punish
giu for breaking core rules and
protecting the demon nezuko by the way
coolness points for the fact that he's
just chilling on the tree while the
others all stand on the ground I gotta
just say that one of the reasons I love
this ship so much is because iguru is
possibly my favorite hashira and I just
love his character he also has one of
the most unique looks with his
differently colored eyes bandages
covering his mouth and a living snake
necklace but of course igoro doesn't
view the snake as a necklace but as a
friend but anyways back to the story
mitsuri responds to igoro's words with a
heart popping up above her head in the
Manga she thinks to herself and I quote
as usual iguro is as coolly menacing as
a snake he's reliable which is nice and
quote she's blushing as well in most
cases it would be clear that she's in
love with him but it's not so clear what
the love of since she also blushes
taking up tanjiro giyu sanami shinobu
and so on the love hasha blushes and has
Hearts coming from her character in
multiple cases which I suppose goes with
the whole being the love hashira thing
thus she has a positive view of iguro
but in the beginning it doesn't seem to
be especially significant because she
has such positive views about the others
as well after all she's a very positive
person Yuro doesn't make it clear that
he's into mitsuri here either he more so
makes it clear that he's pretty ruthless
in contrast to mitsuri who aside from
gyu has the most compassion for tanjiro
and nazuko when sanami wants a test
that's cool iguru is the one that
reminds him that it won't work in the
light and he has to go into the shade
where she won't come out his personality
and behavior are quickly established as
being very different from mitsuris
whereas mitsuri felt pity for tanjiro
and thought he was cute iguro is the one
who quickly elbows him to the ground
when Tundra fails to show respect in
front of their leader and thus we don't
figure out much about these two except
that iguro is one of the many people she
likes and he can be pretty cruel and
ruthless in contrast to mitsuri who is
so positive and compassionate we do see
something that they both have in common
during chapter 66. they're both affected
by then Goku's passing if you didn't
know then Goku trained mitsuri and she
was actually learning flame breathing
before she developed her own style she
raises her hand to her mouth when she
hears of her former mentor's passing
deeply moved we don't see igoro's
expression but he does say he can't
believe it so he's clearly not
indifferent to the news we next see
iguro after the defeat of upper Moon 6.
he shows up to the scene and at first
says he's impressed but that initial bit
of Praise is quickly complicated when he
asks what Tenga is going to do about
losing his hand and an eye in a fight
with a mere upper six again not much
kindness and empathy shown here instead
of being glad Tenga is alive he sort of
insults him for losing limbs to a low
upper Moon and then immediately asks how
long will it take him to recover and who
will replace him in the meantime when
tengen tells him he plans to retire now
iguro thinks it's ridiculous and even
says he won't allow it since they lost
rengoku they desperately need a Slayer
of tankin's caliber even wounded so he
has to fight until he dies what the
manga is doing well here by depicting
iguru as such a ruthless unfeeling dude
is that she's preparing to move us when
we finally find out how much iguro does
care about mitsuri we all know it's all
the more impactful when a seeming jerk
shows his soft side I mean just ask
Bulma from Dragon Ball Z next let's fast
forward to chapter 101 just to see how
much mitsuri eats not only does she eat
more than igurum as I mentioned she eats
way more than tanjiro looks like when
Goku eats and after she finishes all
those dishes and Tundra says impressive
she says she didn't eat that much
tonight implying that she usually eats
more it's after this meal that tanjo
asks mitsuri why she joined the Demon
Slayer core and blushing she answers to
find the man to marry she explains that
it's good for a girl to find someone
stronger than herself someone to protect
her now I know what some of you might be
thinking that iguro is not physically
stronger than mitsuri which is correct
but even if he is not physically
stronger he is the stronger swordsman
and performs better in battle as we'll
see later so as of now we know that the
love hashira is looking for a dude who
is stronger than her and who can protect
her thus her options for ships are
pretty much limited to male hashira
since she's so strong and we can
probably cross out tengen who is weaker
than her at this point and has three
wives already and maybe even Sunday the
wind hashira because mitsuri remarks to
tanjiro that both Shina zugawa Brothers
scare her not to mention we figure out
bonus materials later on that sanami
doesn't like mitsuri's personality and
that sonami and igoro are really good
friends so Sunny would never even go
after mitsu in the first place
especially since he likes someone else
as we'll get into later in the video
anyways since then Goku tragically died
that only leaves Gio iguro gyome and
muichiro as possible options and keep in
mind muichiro is five years younger than
mitsuri at only 14 years old so really
we're looking at three options either
way iguro is quickly becoming more and
more of an option as we narrow down the
possibilities using her own criteria
what's also so relevant for the purposes
of this video is mitsuri's backstory
during chapter 123. we get a flashback
of pretty much how she was told she
can't get married because of how funny
her hair color is pretty strange reason
to say someone can't get married but hey
it happened and that's something you
gotta actually know about mitsuri
because as anime Watchers I think most
of us would just assume her hair is
normal anime hair but in the world of
demons there it's made clear that this
is not the case two years ago she was 17
years old and her marriage Arrangements
fell through we're also told in this
flashback that she's the Eightfold girl
her muscle density is eight times that
of a normal person so if her actual
muscle power was reflected in her body's
appearance she'd look very jacked indeed
at only 13 months old mitsuri lifted a
rock that weighed 33 pounds her mother
was shocked for the first time ever upon
seeing this it's also repeated that she
had a big appetite and could eat get
this more than three sumo wrestlers
combined none of these qualities were
viewed as ladylike and appropriate for a
would-be wife so mitsuri felt like she
had to hide her true self she dyed her
hair black ate so little that she always
felt faint and pretended to be weak
despite the fact that she had superhuman
strength finally a man was ready to
marry this version of her but she didn't
feel right she wondered if there's a
place where she could be herself if
there was a man out there who would
accept her for her true self clearly
mitsuri wasn't looking for a lot just
someone who would like her for her and
she realized that no dude weaker than
her could probably do that based on her
previous experiences which is why she
started searching for someone stronger
significantly on the cover page of 124
we get a huge image of mitsuri smiling
and blushing while she eats iguro is
sitting beside her staring at her with
gentle eyes we're not given the complete
context here but one can imagine that
they are close and that they enjoy each
other's company and that iguro probably
offered to pay to be a gentleman even
though he probably barely ate that last
one might just be my interpretation but
the point is we'd already had her
possible ships narrowed down to about 3
people at this point and now this image
of them together pretty much narrows it
down further to iguru and the clues
about their feelings for each other
don't stop there not by a long shot as
more of mitsuri's backstory is revealed
we find out that instead of getting
married as someone she's not she found
the demonstrator core where her true
self was seen as a blessing not a curse
furthermore she reveals that iguro gave
her the long striped green socks that
she wears higuro can't even look her in
the eye as he gives them and we see two
hearts in midair between them and at
this point when we realize a big part of
her image came from igoro this whole
time it seems obvious that igoro and
mitsuri are into each other and are
probably going to end up together if any
too hush in a will the question is why
aren't they already together and that
will be answered when we get to igoro's
backstory for now let's fast forward to
after mitsuri's fight with upper Moon 4.
the hashra Meetup muichiro beat upper
Moon 5 and mitsuri helped beat upper
Moon 4. sonomi comments that he's
jealous that he never got to fight an
upper moon but igoro actually shows
concern he asks how mitsuring are and
it's so sweet to see mitsuri's face
light up as she says I'm much better
thanks mitsuri blushes and sweats as she
answers iguro and if that wasn't enough
she even thinks herself oh he's worried
about me end quote this is clearly one
of the more focused on ships already and
there will be even more significant
moments that solidify the ship however
you can already tell that there are way
more clues that these two will end up
together than there were for inosuke and
AWI even though these guys get less
screen time than inosuke there's a funny
part here though where they ask mitsuri
and muichiro to explain how they unlock
their Demon Slayer marks mitsuri tries
to explain but is absolutely horrible at
it and everyone is struck by how bad her
explanation was igoro's reaction is
emphasized he even does a face palm she
proceeds to apologize profusely for
being terrible at explaining but it was
cute seeing how affected iguro was by
her embarrassing situation I feel like
this usually stoic dude wouldn't be so
visibly affected by such a situation
unless he cared about mitsuri the hashra
go on to run run their own training
courses and when Tundra gets to igoro's
course we get even more clues as to how
much iguro cares about mitsuri we're
told that the two hasha exchanged
letters and when iguro sees tanjiro he
gets very angry uncharacteristically so
he mentions how mitsuri told him about
tanjiro and how they had quite a lot of
fun in training tanjiro senses that
iguro totally hates him from the start
but it seems more like jealousy because
Tanja got so close to his precious
mitsuri this hypothesis is confirmed
when after Tundra passes the training
iguro specifically warns him not to get
too friendly with mitsuri I love iguru's
expression when he says this his veins
are even popping up on his head so far
they've done a really good job of slowly
but surely sprinkling in the clues about
how iguro feels about mitsuri and about
how mitsuri feels about iguro mitsuri
obviously never gets so overprotective
and jealous over iguro but he does fit
her criteria and it's clear she likes
spending time with him Treasures his
gifts to the point she wears the socks
he gave her every day and she even
blushes and sweat let's at the thought
that he's concerned about her at this
point all we're waiting for is a
confession of Love or an explanation as
to why we haven't gotten it yet and now
we fast forward to the demon Slayers
versus muzon fight part 1. both iguro
and mitsu are present with the others
and probably not a coincidence they're
often shown close to each other in the
panels and as a result of their close
proximity to each other they get Warped
together we get a sweet moment where
some Demon extras show up and igoro
handles them real quick saying and I
quote stay away from kanroji and quote
we know that mitsuri wanted exactly this
someone to protect her and it's not a
surprise that she brightens up and
blushes when she sees this she even
thinks to herself and I quote iguro is
great end quote it's so cute seeing
these two together iguro asks if she's
hurt she says no he says let's go and
she says okay with three hearts floating
in Her speech bubble and I don't think
we've ever seen her blush so hard based
on this she's clearly got the feels for
ikuro too and if you still don't think
these two are perfect together I just
don't get you but we'll get even more
confirmation that they are the two go on
to fight the new upper moon for nakime
and it's not really a fight in the
conventional sense nakime gives them a
lot of trouble but doesn't threaten
their lives that much in other words
she's not especially strong but her
blood demon art is very tricky and makes
her hard to hit as she's Shifting the
dimension around them during this fight
mitsuri gets Hasty and igoro saves her
by grabbing her while she's falling in
midair igoro is so sweet as he tells her
a nice way as long as they don't know
their opponent's abilities they should
watch closely think hard and proceed
calmly the last thing he wants is for
mitritadai later when Tundra is
confronting moves on with Kyu Tundra
sees an image of Igor and mitsuri having
been defeated now it's pretty obvious
there's something fishy here since iguro
was built up big time so having him just
lose off screen would be kind of
ridiculous if mitsuri helped beat the
old upper four it's hard to believe that
her and the stronger iguro couldn't take
down the new replacement still for a
second this might look horrible it looks
like our Romeo and Juliet the couple
whose romantic relationship was probably
emphasized the most in the whole series
might have died without ever confessing
their love to each other in a
straightforward way luckily as we find
out this was again Jutsu via yushiro AKA
Just an Illusion mitsui shows up soon
enough to muzon's shock as this igura
who helps say tanjiro if you pay close
attention you'll also see that mitsuri
is all beat up after the fight with
nakime while iguro doesn't have a
scratch or Speck of dirt on him another
sign of his Advanced skills as the fight
against the hashan muzan goes on it's
mitsuri who starts falling behind as
iguro mentions they can no longer Shield
gomei probably one of the most flexed
lines in the entire series mitsui is
thinking that she can't see muzon at all
she's relying on intuition and luck to
dodge and so she knows she'll be the
first one to fall so while igoro has
been protecting others in addition to
himself mitsuri has been having trouble
just keeping herself alive and she
proves to be correct she's the one who
gets seriously damaged by muzon portion
of her face and arm are taken off and of
course iguro's worried reaction is the
first one we're shown after this happens
once again Ecuador prioritizes her and
is the one who takes her to safety he
leaves her with people who can tend to
her wounds while Mitri is saying she can
still fight iguro though in a touching
moment says no she's done enough iguro
then leaves and a waterfall of Tears
falls down me to his face as she begs
igura not to get himself killed she also
wishes that igoro and her had met under
normal circumstances and we see an image
of them in civilian clothing strolling
in nature like it was a Jane Austen
novel however iguro whose mouth is
finally exposed to reveal a joker-like
snake scar says such a life was
impossible for him we finally see why he
didn't make a move earlier he says
unless I die and get a different body in
which this filthy blood does not flow I
have no right to be with you he has an
inferiority complex which is kind of
funny just because mitsuri obviously has
an inferiority complex as well they both
don't think they're good enough even
though each would be ecstatic to have
the other as a romantic partner iguro
goes on to explain that he belongs to a
club bloodline that has killed to line
its own Pockets with stolen money they
have inhabited mansions feasted and
lived in unnecessary luxury they were a
Shameless avaricious ostentatious and
ugly Clan then we jump into his
backstory I will just say first that it
frustrates me when characters think like
this that they can't be happy and have
to pay for the sins of their bloodline
even if they themselves did nothing
wrong I'm not saying it's bad
storytelling and I'm sure there are
those who blame themselves like iguro
does but I just love iguro so much that
it's hard for me to see him being so
hard on himself but that tangent aside
his backstory is that he was born into a
family of many girls and it had been 370
years since the last boy was born since
birth iguro was confined in a Cell the
woman fond over him and brought him rich
foods there was so much food and the
smell of it made him nauseous in part
this probably explains why he doesn't
eat that much at night he'd hear
something creepy and massive crawling
around when he turned 12 he found out
this was a serpent demon lady this
female demon was worshiped like a God by
the family the family lived off of The
Riches of the people this demon killed
in order to keep her happy the family
offered their newborns to her as a
sacrifice the demon took a special
interest in iguro who was a rare boy
with unusual eyes as a result she
allowed him to grow to a more satiating
size before she would eat him at her
meeting with the 12 year old iguro she
determined that she'd let him live a
little longer and even had his mouth cut
to more closely match her own and the
Jokers oh yeah and she drank the blood
that came from the process very messed
up stuff now back in his cell iguro was
understandably thinking about escaping
and surviving before he gets eaten by a
gross lady demon he used a stolen
hairpin and began scratching away the
lattice of his cell this is the closest
demonstrator gets to a prison break
right here at this point he was very
scared they'd find out and the only
creature he could trust was the snake
kaburamaru who he still has to this day
around his neck I like the fact that
they didn't demonize snakes here and
showed how yeah this snake lady evil but
kaburamaru who was a literal snake is
igoro's best friend there isn't
something inherently bad about snake or
serpent stuff and that's reflected in
the fact that iguro goes on to become
the serpent hashira anyways eventually
he makes his escape with his friend
snake the lady demon finds him but
before she can kill him the flame hashra
saves him this is a cool detail because
this is probably in Goku's father here
before he fell off the rails and became
a pessimistic drunk even though he
eventually fell off it's nice to know
that his Good Deeds that he performed
when he was a hashira continue to have a
huge impact in the present after all
without him we wouldn't have iguro who
was insanely valuable as one of the
strongest and most skilled hashira the
flame hashira brought iguro together
with his only surviving cousin but she
rejected him and this part infuriates me
too because I feel so much for iguro she
blames our boy iguro for killing
everyone why because 50 people died as a
result of him running away they would
have lived if he just played the role of
a happy sacrifice to the demon even
though on some level iguro knew her
words were unjustified her words still
pained him he had thought about what
might happen to them but decided to flee
anyway because he wanted to live he
started viewing himself as corrupt just
like his filthy family his sins were
deep so he could not live a normal life
with no other Outlet he turned his rage
on demons he risked his life for others
and felt as if he had in some way become
a slightly better person each time
nevertheless that the king hands of 50
people whose eyes Shone with reproach
continued to clot at him and hold him
back he wanted him planned to die
defeating muzon and prayed that the deed
would purify his filthy blood then if he
were reborn as a human being in a
peaceful world without demons he would
tell mitsuri of his feelings for her so
that's why he didn't confess his
feelings up to this point he felt like
he was too corrupt and the only way he
may feel okay doing it was if he died
defeating the strongest demon and was
reincarnated like bro you did nothing
wrong I want to tell him his family put
him in that situation and was ready to
sacrifice him so him just trying to
survive is completely understandable
those women who died were guilty of not
only benefiting from the demon killing
others but also for not helping iguro
and countless other babies partnering up
with a demon has its risks and having
the demon suddenly destroy you all is
one of the risks that comes with the
territory so part of me desperately
wishes that iguro didn't feel like this
but don't worry we will get our happy
ending and it'll be perfect even if
oddly iguro has to die first iguro goes
on to be absolutely amazing in the fight
against muzon as I outlined in my how
strong is iguro video long story short
igoro fulfills his wish he puts up a
valiant effort against muzon Awakening
the Demon Slayer Mark turning his blade
red and gaining access to the
transparent world in the process it's
touching to see how he thinks about him
and mitsuri as a team and thinks that he
needs to hang in there and fight harder
to make up for mitsuri's absence and he
really does make up for her absence
since he's the first hasha to get up
after muzon wrecks them and saves
tanjiro even though he's lost his vision
by this point and has to rely on
kaburamaru by the way how awesome is
this snake if you agree you should smash
that like button right now for
kaburamaru after they defeat muzon we
see iguro holding mitsuri they are both
dying from their wounds Mitri apologizes
for not being much use in this fight but
iguro tells her to please not say that
he reminds her of the first time they
met iguro says she was such a normal
girl when they met and that saved him
she got excited over the smallest things
and her laughter was like Belle's
ringing it was love at first sight
pretty much iguru enjoyed talking to her
and was happy feeling like a normal boy
all the while he says her bottomless
cheerfulness and kindness saved many
people so she should be proud igoro
would never let anyone say otherwise and
this is the part where I was probably
bawling when reading and even now my
eyes are getting kind of watery not
gonna lie mitsuri cries too saying she's
so happy and she cares about iguro so
much this is her side of the confession
here she says meals always tasted best
with him because he looked at her with
so much affection she says please igoro
if we're reborn and we're humans can I
be your bride and now even this usually
stoic dude is crying and he says yes of
course if you will agree to have me it's
one of if not the sweetest moments in
Demon Slayer he continues saying this
time I'll make you happy and protect you
so you don't die and they both pass away
in each other's Embrace probably happier
than they've ever been in their lives
now if you don't know what happens you
might be like gozan how's that a happy
ending they both died right when they
were supposed to start their lives as an
official couple but remember what keeps
being mentioned in their relationship
Arc the idea of reincarnation and being
together in that peaceful world that
actually comes to fruition in chapter
205 and it's my favorite part of that
chapter in this chapter we get a huge
time Skip and we see the descendants of
those who survived the fight with muzon
and the reincarnations of those who lost
their lives fighting him we see the
reincarnated versions of mitsuri and
iguro on page 10 and it is so fulfilling
and satisfying the perfect happy ending
that they hope for they own a Family
Diner together they offer for huge
servings a mitsuri touch and have snake
decor and iguro touch we even find out
that iguro just like in his old life got
jealous when yoshiteru zanito and
nazuku's descendant wouldn't stop
staring at me to his chest so igorov now
a cook threw a knife at them the throne
knife aside we can imagine that they are
a very happy married couple and
mitsuri's reincarnation just like in her
past life completely lights up the room
with her smile this romantic pairing had
the most outwardly romantic moments in
the series while the others discussed
seemed to stay more so in the background
until the end I feel like this one was
very much in the foreground for these
characters if that makes sense it never
felt like an afterthought absolutely
loved them both individually and love
them both together too and after this
video I gotta say this is at least tied
for my favorite couple and maybe even is
my favorite couple in all of Demon
Slayer don't forget to let me know who
your favorite demon slaying couple is in
the comments however this next couple is
not a demon slaying couple next up we
have upper Moon 3 off
backstory hits the hardest out of any
demons for me it's easy to hate the guy
for taking the life of one of the best
anime characters to ever exist kyojiro
rengoku but akasa's backstory makes him
by far one of the most likable demons in
the series and a big part of that is due
to his love story with a girl named
koyuki when he was a human akaza went by
the name hakuji his life was hard as a
kid he only had his father and his
father was sick he needed medicine but
they were poor and couldn't afford it
thus rather than let his father die
akasa stole so he could bring back
medicine he was beaten up for it he got
three tattoos on his arms for getting
caught three times next time they would
take his hand they warned him but he
didn't care he'd steal with his feet if
he had to tragically when he heard
hakuji got arrested his father took his
own life not wanting to trouble his son
he thought this would help hakuji live a
righteous life however hakuji saw it
very differently he never thought of his
father as a burden or a bother and would
have taken any punishment gladly in
order to help him hakuchi was devastated
when his father took his life he was
lost and got into more fights until he
met the father of his love keso who owns
a dojo how could you try to attack Hazel
too when he showed up but got his butt
kicked not only did Kazo take him on as
a student he also trusted hakuji to take
care of his sick daughter despite the
fact that hakuji had the tattoos of a
criminal when hakuji meets daughter
koyuki she reminds him of his sick
father in a sense he has a chance to
redeem himself by helping to save her in
a way that he couldn't save his father
hakuji was more than happy to stay up
all night changing the towels on her
forehead and her betting he gave her
water and took her to the bathroom when
she needed to go he hated how sick
people apologize for being an
inconvenience because he knew that
they'd love to do all these things for
themselves if they could and they were
the ones suffering the most crazy to
think that the world viewed someone like
him as a criminal and a demon child but
Kaizo didn't and because of kazo's trust
hakuji got a second chance he didn't
mind not being able to do other things
and have fun because as he says he never
thinks about fun in his free time he
just trains so pay no mind he tells
koyuki she doesn't know it but she gave
hakuji a new purpose when he thought
that he had nothing to live for anymore
one day she tells him that he should get
away from his nursing responsibilities
and go see the fireworks that will be
launched at night how could she refuses
to go alone though and says that's right
and offers to carry her to the foot of
the bridge so they could enjoy them
together he even says if she can't go
today then they can go next year or the
year after that to enjoy them this
kindness made koyuki Cry which in turn
made hakuji uncomfortable during one
conversation Kaizo tells hakoji that
they are the same and that they both
need something to protect and now koyuki
was clearly that something for hakuji
three years passed with hakuji helping
koyuki he was now 18 and she was 16. now
she was feeling a lot better it seems
hakuji successfully nursed her back to
hell she was up and around and able to
live normally what's more casual told
hakuji that he wanted him to be his
successor for the dojo since after all
koyuki liked him so hakuji went from
losing everything and having nothing to
being offered a dojo and koyuki's hand
in marriage it's cute how hakuji sweats
and turns red as he hears this while
koyuki similarly blushes and looks down
to avoid eye contact hakuji of course
accepts the offer he never thought
someone like him could have a bright
future but now he's hopeful he looks at
the overjoyed koyuki and smiling Kaizo
and thanks to himself that he would give
his life to protect these two we get a
beautiful scene where finally hakuji and
koyuki make it to see the fireworks
hakuji was wondering if he's really good
enough for koyuki and she reminds him
that when she was a child he spoke to
her about going to see the fireworks
those silly talks with him made her
happy she liked how he said that they'd
see the fireworks the year after or the
year after that if she couldn't make it
that night before that she couldn't
imagine living into the next year her
mother took her own life because she was
the same way and didn't want to see her
daughter die she knew her father had
given up as well because she was so
terribly weak but hakuji could see her
future as if it was a matter of fact and
he talked to her about the next year and
the year after that and she was very
happy she then grabs his hand and while
blushing tells him yes he is good enough
and asks him to marry her he says yes
and says he will become stronger than
anyone and protect her with his life
meanwhile the fireworks explode
beautifully in the background it's
really the perfect night but just as
hakuji gets a taste of his own personal
Heaven it's ripped from him when the
jealous rival Dojo poisons there well as
a result while hakuji is away visiting
his father's grave keizo and koyuki die
from poisoning after losing his father
and everything that made his life worth
living slowly but surely he got on the
right path again his heart healed and he
opened it up again only to lose it all
once more I don't think anyone can blame
hakuji for snapping here he killed 67
members of the Rival Dojo with his bare
hands a surviving maid witnessed the
Carnage and lost her mind the story was
thought to be so crazy it after 30 years
the record of the event was disposed of
as a fabrication but it really did
happen muzon heard about it and came to
check on this demon sighting only to
find the human hakuji covered in blood
it's not that muzon turned hakuji into a
demon against his will it's that hakuji
no longer had a reason to live in his
View and didn't care anymore about
anything thus muzan was able to turn him
into the demon akaza he lost his
memories and began seeking power again
notably though there were remnants of
his human life for instance he was the
only demon moon to refuse to eat or kill
women despite the fact that women are
especially nutritious for demons in the
Demon Slayer world this was even cited
as being a possible reason for akasa
being weaker than Doma despite the fact
that he became a demon first it goes to
show that even as a demon with no
memories there were still some
principles that he refused to betray for
power furthermore his compass needle
technique forms the shape of a snowflake
a reference to his fiancee koyuki whose
name contains the kanji for snow and who
wore snowflake shaped hair airpins
similarly his attacks are named after
fireworks and as we've just seen
fireworks held a very special
significance in the context of hakuji
and koyuki's relationship however this
love story doesn't end on a tragic note
koyuki's Spirit comes back to wakaza
during his fight with tanjiro and guiyu
and in fact it's her influence that lets
him overpower muzon's influence his
Spirit cries in her arms and begs for
forgiveness as she welcomes her love
home with that reunion his demon body is
finally allowed to cease regenerating
and disappear yorichi X utta next let's
look at the strongest demon sair in
history's love story of course I speak
of yorichitsugikuni the man who created
the original and strongest breath style
Sun breathing when he ran away as a kid
from home he eventually met a girl about
his age called utta she was just
standing there and not moving for a long
time so he asked what she was doing she
answered that her family died in a
plague she says she's all alone and very
lonely so she came there to find some
tadpoles to take home but she freed the
tadpoles saying she felt sorry about
separating them from their families the
young urichi says they'll accompany her
home and she looks at him and cries they
decide to live together UTA would talk
from morning to night and thanks to her
yorichi learned how to see the world in
different ways yorichi describes their
relationship this way he says he was
always like a kite whose string had been
broken but utta held onto his hand
firmly ten years later they got married
and they got pregnant eventually it was
time for yorichi to get a midwife so he
set out for one he planned to return
before the sunset but he ended up
helping an old man along the way even
though he headed home right after that
and planned to summon the Midwife
tomorrow because he was running late
night fell before he arrived when he
arrived both utta and their unborn child
had been killed as yorichi tells
sumiyoshi tanjos ancestor another person
may not hesitate to trample upon someone
whose life you value more than your own
for 10 days yorichi was in a daze as he
cradled their bodies eventually an
ancestor of kyojuros a source has been
in pursuit of a demon showed up and saw
the scene he encouraged yurichi to mourn
them properly through prayer as yarichi
explains his dream was to live a quiet
life with his family in a small house
where they would sleep side by side he
would be close enough to see the faces
of his beloved wife and child and close
enough to reach out and take their hands
that would have been enough for him even
if he was the greatest swordsman to ever
exist and I really like how demonstrator
questions whether ambition or being the
best is important as both yurichi and
tanjiro are the type to be satisfied by
simple peaceful lives that is the
perfect happy ending for tanjiro it just
so happens that he needs to get strong
to reach that ending while people who
are obsessed with being the best for its
own sake like yurichi's brother
kokushibu end up trading their souls for
it and still don't reach their goal but
back to yurichi's backstory and you can
see why after his wife and child were
killed by a demon he would decide to
turn his attention to eradicating Demons
since he didn't want anyone else to go
through what he had tengen X his three
wives then of course there's the sound
hashira tengen uzui and his three wives
makio Suma and hinatsuru although you
might want to hate on Tangen for having
three wives like yutaro do I actually
like how demonstrator has an open mind
with this four-way romance it wasn't
even Tegan's choice to begin with in the
first fan book tangyen's ninja families
practice of polygamies explained at 15 a
boy must have three wives the head of
the clan will choose the wives and they
do take chemistry into account when
picking furthermore tanking clearly
cares deeply about his wives as he tells
them to always think about their lives
first he says they are more important
than any Mission he doesn't care what
they have to leave behind just to make
sure to return to him that positions
tengen in a very positive light when
compared to his father's brutal ninja
ways even tengen tells them that his
ways may sound strange given their
profession but that's how he wants it he
tells them day three come first then
reliable assistance and then tangent
himself so you gotta respect how he puts
each and every one of them above himself
he lets them know that they are the most
important thing to him so they can't let
themselves get killed he also passed
them on the head and compliments them
which is nice and completely different
from what they've been taught to expect
as female ninjas bonus points if you
know the Japanese term for female ninjas
just write down the comments tangan's
care and kindness are reciprocated by
his wives who always want to help him
and are visibly devastated when they see
the dire situation he is in after the
gyutaro fight and I like the way each of
his wives is different but they all love
him in their own way for instance when
he had the habit of saying he'd go to
hell it upsets all his wives so much
that he stopped saying it but what's
interesting is that they all responded
differently when he used to say it Macio
got angry hinatsuru cried and Suma bit
him that biting part specifically gets
me every time after this battle as the
four discussed beforehand they retire
from demon slaying which is fair because
they did their part I like that not
everyone needs to fight to the death
they got different paths be besides
tangent would obviously be less useful
anyway after losing his arm and eye yes
tangent helps here and there with
training or protection but nothing as
dangerous as he did before and I'm sure
his wives are relieved about that
notably the once friendless guy you
befriends Tangen and his family after
the final battle with muzon were even
told in the second fan book that when
Tegan's child was born guiyu was allowed
to hold the baby but which one of the
three wives gave birth to her child I
couldn't tell you either way I'm sure
they all rejoiced and teamed up to raise
the ninja baby together sonomi X Kanai
yes always angry bad boy son of me
actually had a soft spot for a girl
specifically for shinobu's older sister
Kane who was the flower hashira before
upper Moon 2 Doma took her life in the
second fan book Joe may pretty much
reveals who every hasha likes and when
it comes to sanami he says and I quote
he seems to like Kane and quote sunmi
himself says he talks to shinobu now and
then since she's kind of his little
sister after kind of death whenever they
meet he asks shinobu if she's doing okay
doesn't sound like the son of me would
get in the anime but it makes sense when
you consider this is the little sister
of the woman he loved even in the
alternate universe of kimetsu Academy
where sonomi is a math teacher he talks
to kind of frequently showing in a way
that their love transcends universes
Tamayo X yushiro now this is more of a
one-sided romance but that one side is
so devoted that it must be mentioned
Tamayo never got over the loss of her
husband and children so I don't think
she could ever romantically open up
after that however after she saved
yushiro from an illness by turning him
into a demon she let him become her
personal assistant he was so in love and
obsessed with her that he would be very
overprotective of her to the point where
it even bothered him when nezuko hugged
her when he senses tamayo's death
yushiro's enraged expression on page 17
of chapter 180 says it all to say that
she was the most important person in his
life would be an understatement but
what's most admirable about this
one-sided romance is just how undying
your love is demon yushiro survived into
the modern day as we see during chapter
205 which on a side note interestingly
proves that demons can survive even if
the demon that turned them passes away
so if they wanted to do a sequel they
could definitely make it so that
surviving demons pop up here and there
just saying but back to the modern day
and yushiro is now a mysterious artist
who has not only never moved on from
Tamayo but now paints picture after
picture of Tamayo his work is even
beginning to receive critical acclaims
zany choose to send in comments that his
favorite is number 812 meaning there
could well be a thousand or more
paintings of Tamayo by now and Counting
so even though it may be sad that
yushiro's love was never required it's
beautiful how untainted and undying his
love is after centuries it was one of my
favorite details about the time Skip and
Final Chapter kiux shinobu we're finally
here now this is one of the most popular
ships in the Demon Slayer fandom but is
it Canon or just fans pushing them
together let's look at at the evidence
in the anime the two are fairly close at
least as close as anyone could be to
loner guiyu at this point yes there was
the whole shinobu's heal blade almost
stabbing you in the face thing but
notably she's the one who defends you in
front of the hashira after you Breaks
the Rules iguru is out for blood as
mentioned while shinobu says we needn't
worry about him he came along without a
fight so even though shinobu sometimes
teases gyu to his face she actually
defends him in front of others fans have
also picked up on when shinobu said
isn't the moon lovely in the anime and
Geo agreed isn't the moon lovely is said
to be a poetic way to say I love you in
Japanese if that's not enough ammo for
shippers shinobu is also in gyu's
spin-off in the stories of water and
Flame volume after she joins him on his
mission the two eat together and Geo
even cracks a smile in her presence
which I hope I don't need to tell you is
exceedingly rare for guiyu iguro and
mitsuri who also loved each other would
eat like this together as well then as I
mentioned there is what gyome said in
the second fan book book he said
Chernobyl seems to enjoy talking with
Kyu and that gyu seems happy talking
with shinobu for her part shinobu said
she thinks guiyu should talk a bit more
implying that she'd like him to open up
to her more while Gio comments that
shinobu talks from often he says she's
Earnest and hardworking and that she
looks unwell at times this last line
arguably shows that he worries about her
lastly the usually stoicio is visibly
affected by the news that shinobu is
dead during chapter 144. albeit he
doesn't cry like tanjiro does so
although they don't get together in the
end it's not difficult to believe that
they would have if shinobu's life wasn't
tragically cut short because of demons
and that is it for every secret romance
in Demon Slayer in my longest video on
YouTube If you appreciate the amount of
work and time that went into this please
smash that like button to let me know
until you see fireworks akaza X koyuki
style and of course subscribe but that's
far from all the secrets in the series
if you like learning about the
demonstrator secrets from fun to
straight shocking then you don't want to
miss my 101 demonstrator secrets you
didn't know video link on screen right
now in the description see you there